[Musique]
terrasse avec vue sur le large les
collines de lisbonne forme le berceau
européen du métissage
lisbonne à la croisée des continents qui
la nuit venue résonne du blues des
insulaires
[Musique]
ce chant c'est la morna l'emblème du cap
vert
[Musique]
célina pereira chante la morna depuis
toujours la morna raconte ce mal du pays
qu'on appelle la sodade et que cesaria
evora icône du genre chanter dans ce
même bistrot il ya 20 ans
la musique fait partie de notre vie de
la naissance jusqu'à notre mort
la musique est trop précieuse pas
l'homme pour qu'on ne la considère pas
comme notre second drapeau national
[Musique]
dans ce bistrot historique des cap
verdiens de lisbonne on sert un punch
redoutable et un cassoulet locale
impérial
[Musique]
vous avez rangé dans le manioc la draft
d'humaniste du my way
célina et ses amis sont arrivés à
lisbonne il y a plus de 30 ans alors que
leur pays était encore une colonie
portugaise aujourd'hui ils sont artistes
avocat ou médecin ils sont ces
capverdien qui ont réussi ici au
portugal
il y a quelque chose de très beau dans
cette dualité d'être portugais et cap
verdien en même temps et de leur
présenter à chaque instant
l'histoire du cap vert et du portugal
sont indissociables le cap vert ce sont
10 il planté au large du sénégal un
archipel encore inhabitée il y a cinq
siècles que les portugais ont transformé
en comptoir à esclave l'afrique l'europe
et le nouveau monde s'y croisent de
l'année une identité et une langue le
créole capverdien sous la dictature de
salazar le cap vert sert de réservoir de
main d'oeuvre à la métropole portugaise
l'archipel n'obtiendra son indépendance
qu'en 1975 aujourd'hui sur les dix îles
du cap-vert vivent 400 mille personnes
mais ils sont 800 milles à travers le
monde cette diaspora qu'on appelle la
11e îles du cap-vert et son premier port
d'attache c'est lisbonne
le portugal en tant que pays d'accueil
n'a pas suffisamment valorisé la culture
de ces migrants
à eau de la police pour les ouvrages
heureusement les choses changent rien
encore un long chemin à parcourir ap
mais cette maternité se construit
notamment avec les amis qui sont ici
pour tout étudiant
il y à toutes les générations venues du
monde entier au cap-vert allemagne
hollande angleterre la guinée-bissau si
c'est ça l'histoire du cap vert
dans ce bistrot lisboète célina et ses
amis semblent avoir digéré les rapports
coloniaux du passé c'est cap verdien
donne l'image d'une culture mosaïque et
apaisées
[Musique]
mais à lisbonne la vie des cap verdiens
n'est pas toujours aussi douce la
nostalgie du pays laisse place aux
soucis du quotidien bienvenu akoha
d'amour à une banlieue bidonvilles à 15
km du centre de lisbonne
kova d'amour à ses 10000 habitants dont
8000 cap verdien un taux de pauvreté
parmi les plus élevés du portugal on ne
dirait pas comme ça mais le quartier est
réputé pour être l'un des plus mal famé
de la capitale il fait régulièrement la
une des médias pour ses trafics et ses
descentes de flics
pour les plus jeunes du quartier jak il
sonne c'est un peu le grand frère
là on va la bibliothèque c'est là bas
que je travaille
jack wilson et mai au cap vert mais a
grandi acova d'amour à il est éducateur
pour l'association du quartier
avec lui tous les soirs après la classe
les mares mon atelier de slam
je sais pas ce qui rime avec isabelle
parcelles carrousel miel
à la maison et dans le quartier les
jeunes parlant en créole mais ici on
cherche des rimes en portugais histoire
de ne pas décrocher de l'école
moi tout ce que j'espère c'est que leur
avenir sera bien meilleur que celui qu'a
eu ma génération
il faut dire que la génération de jack
wilson a cruellement manqué de
perspectives leurs parents sont venus
acova d'amour à pour travailler dans les
usines environnantes
aujourd'hui les usines ont disparu mais
le ghetto est resté une histoire de
banlieue une musique bien connu en
france mais ici on rappe en créant
nbc le pote de jack wilson a fait des
études mais n'a pas décroché de jobs
pour autant
la question ici c'est qu'il ya une
criminalisation de l'espace géographique
acova d'amaury
discrimination d'une génération des
noirs ainsi au portugal et nommé tour je
suis diplômé et dans mon cv je ne peux
pas mettre l'adresse de la coved à mort
parce que l'homme qui va l'analyser va
regarder et dire mon dieu ce gala cauvin
d'amora tu vois ce que je veux dire
alors les jeunes de covan amour a
rappelé leur frustration et comme
toujours avec les cap verdiens c'est la
musique et les mots qui transcende le
quotidien
[Musique]
elle tape sur des coussins et ça leur
fait du bien elles ce sont les bas tout
cas des races leur art le batuk c'est la
plus vieille expression musicale du cap
vert
[Musique]
pas de problème il ya la crise mais on a
la joie j'envoie un message au premier
ministre du portugal ne nous donne pas
la paille nous on a besoin de manger ne
nous en ait pas notre joie de vivre
vive l'afrique vive le portugal
le batuk c'est le rap des origines les
familles clament leurs joies et leurs
peines
célina pereira notre chanteuse de mornas
est devenue la marraine débat tout cas
des races
cette tradition qui était plus prudent
le passé est aujourd'hui très recherchée
par les jeunes en
recherche d'identité
il y a quinze ans et femme vivait dans
ce quartier considéré comme l'une des
banlieues chaudes de lisbonne là où plus
un portugais nous est rentré elles ont
alors ressorti cette tradition pour
redorer leur image et ça ne s'est plus
jamais arrêté on a besoin de ce bateau
pour aller de l'avant ça fait 15 ans
qu'on mène cette lutte avec le batuque
on luttera jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'à la fin
voilà de l'argent ça suffit la tristesse
la tristesse ne paye pas les des neiges
créances faisait nuit nous voulons faire
des choses gaies à tous c'est le
mouvement là dedans
et
il y a des rues comme ça où l'on ne sait
plus très bien si l'on n'a pas échoué au
cap vert les capverdiens lisbonne
rappelle taux portugais que la musique
est encore la meilleure façon de dire
merde aux galères
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m